Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and religious intolerance. A warning and a lesson from the past, always worth telling. Except, of course, that none of it is true. So that was Mark Gregory Pegg in A Most Holy War, The Albigensian Crusade and the Battle for Christendom, the story of the Cathars. And Tom, you ended our last episode, renowned historian Tom Holland, with that quotation.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，以及宗教不宽容。来自过去的警告与教训，永远值得诉说。当然，除了其中没有一句是真的。这就是马克·格雷戈里·佩格（Mark Gregory Pegg）在《最圣洁的战争：阿尔比十字军东征与基督教世界的争夺》（A Most Holy War, The Albigensian Crusade and the Battle for Christendom）中讲述的关于卡特里派的故事。汤姆，你用这段引言结束了我们上一集的节目，著名历史学家汤姆·霍兰。
We discussed the book The Da Vinci Code by Dan Brown. We talked about the Holy Blood of fantasists and con artists and hoaxers whose fake manuscripts and stories of buried treasure and buried bloodlines ultimately all flowed into the success of dan brown's the da vinci code and behind it all is the story of this shadowy secretive sort of shadow church i suppose yeah, called the Cathars in the Middle Ages. And you ended by with that quotation effectively saying that it's not just that the conspiracy theories from the novels are not true, but that a lot of the history may not even be true. Well, specifically, histories that were written in the 70s through to the beginning of the 21st
我们讨论了丹·布朗的小说《达芬奇密码》。我们谈到了那些狂想者、骗子和造假者的“圣血”传说，他们伪造的手稿以及关于埋藏的宝藏和隐秘血脉的故事，最终都汇聚成了丹·布朗《达芬奇密码》的成功；而在这一切的背后，是中世纪一个隐秘而神秘的“影子教会”的故事，对吧，也就是中世纪的卡特里派。你最后以这段引言作结，实际上是说，不仅小说中的阴谋论不是真的，而且很多历史本身甚至也可能不是真的。好吧，具体来说，是那些在20世纪70年代到21世纪初编写的历史，
century, and that in a sense, they are kind of highbrow versions of the Da Vinci Code, that both of them are recycling conspiracy theories that are not actually true. So just to sort of, as an incredibly accessible sort of summary, for those people who are completely ignorant of all this, the standard view that you would find in a sort of encyclopedia or something if i looked up the cathars yeah well or wikipedia i mean it's still very much there on what would it what would it tell us who are they and where and so it would say that the cathars are a kind of shadowy counter church in the middle ages that they are based in uh longadoc the midi south of france that they are dualist in In other words, they believe that there is a kind of malign God and a good God, that matter is evil and that spirit is good, that these are ideas that derive from ancient heresies, that they are part of a living tradition that went underground in the Byzantine Empire, that in the 11th and 12th centuries passed from byzantium to bulgaria and a set called the
从某种意义上说，它们其实是《达芬奇密码》的高雅版本，两者都在反复兜售那些实际上并不真实的阴谋论。因此，为了给那些对这一切完全一无所知的人做一个极其通俗易懂的总结：如果你去查阅某种百科全书或类似资料，关于卡特里派的标准观点会是什么样？是的，或者维基百科——我的意思是，它现在依然很大程度上存在于那里——它会告诉我们什么？他们是谁？在哪里？所以它会说，卡特里派是中世纪的一种神秘的“反教会”；他们总部设在法国南部的朗格多克（Languedoc）地区；他们是二元论者。换句话说，他们相信存在一个某种程度上带有恶意的神和一个善神，物质是邪恶的，而精神是善良的；这些观念源自古代异端，是潜入拜占庭帝国的某种活生生传统的一部分；在11和12世纪，这些观念从拜占庭传到了保加利亚以及一个名为
bogomils who then had missionaries who came to the west and they seeded this church and that these people were called cathars this is this is who they were and that they were part of a kind of wider organized european wide kind of church of of heretics and that this then precipitates that the existence of this cathar church precipitates in the beginning of the 13th century the first crusade to be targeted against people within the fabric of christendom rather than beyond it yeah and that over the course of the 13th and 14th century all traces of the cathar church are wiped out both by military campaigning and then after that by the action of inquisitors and by the middle of the 14th century the catholic church has vanished and by
波格米派（Bogomils）的派别，该派随后派遣传教士来到西方，播下了这个教会的种子；这些人被称为卡特里派——这就是他们的来历，他们是欧洲范围内更广泛、更有组织的异端教会的一部分；而这种卡特里派教会的存在，随后在13世纪初引发了第一次十字军东征，其打击目标是基督教世界内部的人，而不是外部的人。是的。在13和14世纪期间，卡特里派教会的一切痕迹都被彻底抹去，先是通过军事战役，接着是通过宗教裁判所的行动；到了14世纪中叶，天主教会已经消失了，并且……
and and by the way that's not not just the the version that you see on wikipedia or in encyclopedias i mean we were talking in the last episode about both of us have been i mean independently of each other i might add to the long dock to see the castles and the sites. And the tourist board massively pushes this. I mean, this is Cathar country, Cathar castles. It's pay Cathar, Cathar country. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
顺便说一句，这不仅仅是你能在维基百科或百科全书中看到的版本——我的意思是，我们在上一集中讨论过，我们俩都曾——我顺便提一句，是各自独立地——去过朗格多克参观那些城堡和遗址。旅游局在大力推销这一点。我的意思是，这就是卡特里派之乡，卡特里派城堡。这里是“卡特里派之乡”（Pays Cathare）。是的，完全正确，完全正确。
So, I mean, so it seems kind of astonishing that a historian could say that none of it is true. And before I go on to say about why this might be the case, two things to make clear. The first is that by the standards of the Catholic Church in the Middle Ages, there absolutely were heretics in the long dock. There were people who by the standards of the Catholic inquisitors ranked as heretics. And the second is that the crusade, I mean, clearly is unspeakably brutal. So Mark Gregory Pegg, who I was quoting, I mean, he describes it actually as the genesis of an entire tradition of genocide within Western history. So it's not that he is downplaying it in any way. But basically, there are two things
所以，我的意思是，历史学家竟然会说这一切都不是真的，这听在我耳中简直令人震惊。在我继续阐述这为什么可能是真的之前，有两点需要明确。首先，按照中世纪天主教会的标准，朗格多克绝对存在异端。确实有一些人，按照天主教宗教裁判所的标准，被归类为异端。其次，十字军东征——我的意思是，显然极其残酷。我刚才引述的马克·格雷戈里·佩格，实际上将其描述为西方历史中整个种族灭绝传统的起源。所以，他绝不是在轻描淡写。但基本上，有两点
he argues and other historians are increasingly arguing that the standard accounts get wrong. The first is that the word Cathar is a misnomer. There were no people who identified themselves as Cathars or who were identified by the Catholic Church as Cathars in Languedoc. So people didn't even use the word? So we've come to where does the word Cathar, how does it come to be used in a minute? But the other thing is that there was no dualist heresy. It did not have roots reaching back into antiquity. It did not come from Byzantium. It did not come from Bulgaria. And it was not part of a wider organized heretic church.
是他以及其他越来越多的历史学家所认为的，标准记述弄错了。首先，“卡特里派”（Cathar）这个词用错了。在朗格多克，没有任何人自称为卡特里派，也没有任何人被天主教会识别为卡特里派。所以人们根本没有用过这个词？那么我们等一下再来讨论“卡特里派”这个词是从哪里来的、它是怎么被使用的。但另一件事是，根本没有所谓的二元论异端。它没有延伸到古代的根基，它不是来自拜占庭，它不是来自保加利亚，它也不是一个更广泛的有组织的异端教会的一部分。
None of those things are true. When you say dualist heresy, so that's the idea that there are two gods? Is it? Or God and the devil? There are two gods and it's matter and spirit. Yes, exactly. So kind of ultimately it's a Persian idea. Manicheanism yes mani who was a prophet who preached this idea that the world was divided by rival gods each
这些全都不是真的。当你提到二元论异端时，这就是指存在两个神的观点吗？是这样吗？还是上帝与魔鬼？存在两个神，分别是物质与精神。是的，完全正确。所以从根本上说，这是一个波斯的概念。摩尼教（Manicheanism）——是的，摩尼是一位先知，他宣扬这样一种观点：世界被彼此竞争的神明所分裂，每一个神明
representing matter and spirit evil and good and this is what the the cathars believe that none of that is true none of that is true so where does the word cathar come from? And I will quote another extremely distinguished historian on this. And this is historian R.I. Moore, Bob Moore, who he wrote a fantastic book called Europe's First Revolution about the 11th century and its aftermath. I would say he's not just one of Britain's greatest medieval historians, he's one of Britain's greatest historians, full stop. And he wrote a fantastic book called The War on Heresy. It came out, I think, in 2014. And it is described on the cover as startling, unsettling and revelatory by a top podcaster. Namely myself. I was going to say, is it Al Murray? So it's a really eye-opening book. And I still remember the kind of, you know, when you read a work of history and it gives you a kind of intellectual thrill yeah absolutely a bit like the da vinci code but in a
分别代表物质与精神、邪恶与善良；这就是卡特里派所信仰的。但这一切都不是真的，全都不是真的！那么“卡特里派”这个词究竟是从哪里来的呢？我将引用另一位极其杰出的历史学家对此的看法。这就是历史学家R·I·摩尔（R. I. Moore），也就是鲍勃·摩尔（Bob Moore），他写过一本非常棒的书，名为《欧洲的第一次革命》（Europe's First Revolution），讲述的是11世纪及其后的历史。我认为他不仅是英国最伟大的中世纪历史学家之一，而且是英国最伟大的历史学家之一，没有之一。他写过一本极好的书，叫作《反异端战争》（The War on Heresy）。我想它出版于2014年。封面上有某位顶级播客对它的评价，称其为“令人震惊、不安且具有启示意义”。也就是我自己。我本想说是阿尔·默里（Al Murray）呢。所以这是一本让人大开眼界的书。我仍然记得那种——你知道的，当你阅读一部历史著作时，它能给你带来一种智力上的颤抖，真是妙不可言，有点像《达芬奇密码》，但在一个
very very you know different plateau but it's a kind of you read it you think i can't quite believe this but actually it all makes sense it's really really exciting it's one of those books i read a book called when montezuma met cortez by a guy called matthew restall and and i think it's the same thing it's a one of those books that basically says, the narrative that you have been reading all your life is wrong. And here is why. And it's a wonderful feeling as a historian to read a book like that. It is.
非常非常——你知道的，不同的层面上。但这种感觉就是，你读完后会觉得：“我简直不敢相信这是真的，但事实上这一切都说得通，真的太激动人心了。”这是那种我读过的书之一。我曾读过一本书，叫作《当蒙特祖玛遇见科尔特斯》（When Montezuma Met Cortez），作者叫马修·雷斯托尔（Matthew Restall），我认为也是这种感觉。它就是那种基本上在说“你读了一辈子的叙事其实是错的，原因就在这里”的书。作为一名历史学家，读到这样一本书是一种美妙的感觉。确实如此。
So it's a bit like when I was 12 and I read The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail. I didn't know any better. I was kind of completely convinced by it. I was kind of convinced by Moore's book, The War on Heresy, because, you know, he is one of the great historians of the Middle Ages. And so you know that you're in safe hands with him. And I will now read what he says about the use of the word Cathar and the fact that there was such a thing as Cathars in the period. Among the many obstacles, Moore writes, placed in the way of this account by fun-hating historians, so namely himself and Pegg. The simplest, though one of the most recently articulated, is that nobody in the 13th century pei kathar, so the kathar country, accused or
所以这有点像我12岁时读《圣血与圣杯》（The Holy Blood and The Holy Grail）时的感觉。那时我什么都不懂，简直对它深信不疑。而我之所以对摩尔的《反异端战争》深信不疑，是因为——你知道的，他是中世纪领域最伟大的历史学家之一，所以你知道跟着他是绝对稳妥的。我现在要读一段他关于“卡特里派”一词的使用以及该时期是否存在卡特里派这类事物的论述。摩尔写道，在那些“痛恨乐趣的历史学家”——也就是他自己和佩格——试图否定这一说法的众多障碍中，
accuser, actually used the word kathar. It does not occur in the large body of letters and sermons denouncing heresy in the region from the middle of the 12th century in the records of the region's inquisitions, or indeed in any medieval source directly from it. So basically, it just wasn't used there. Right. Yes. How come historians are using it? And the answer to that is that it's used in the middle of the 19th century by a French Protestant historian called Charles Schmitt, who publishes a book in 1849 that uses the word Qatar in the title. He was a very great scholar. I mean, hugely influential on the study of this whole kind of field and area. But it's still not being widely used by historians until really the post-war period. So it starts to be used in France, very much around the time that
最简单、尽管也是最新近才被明确提出的一点是：在13世纪的“卡特里派之乡”（Pays Cathare），无论是被指控者还是指控者，其实都没有人使用过“卡特里派”这个词。在12世纪中期以来谴责该地区异端的庞大信件和布道文集锦中，在地区宗教裁判所的记录中，或者在任何直接源自该地区的中古时期文献中，它都没有出现过。所以基本上，那里的人根本就不用这个词。没错。是的。那为什么历史学家们在用呢？答案是，它是在19世纪中期被一位名叫查尔斯·施密特（Charles Schmitt）的法国新教历史学家所使用的，他在1849年出版了一本书，书名中使用了“卡特里派”（Qatar，此处拼写同音）这个词。他是一位非常伟大的学者——我的意思是，对整个这一领域的研究产生了巨大的影响。但在战后时期真正到来之前，它仍然没有被历史学家广泛使用。所以它开始在法国被使用，大约正值
Plantard is starting, you know, who we talked about in the previous episode, is starting to make up his stuff about the Priory of Zion. This is a kind of posh, you know, academic equivalent. The French scholars are starting to use the word Qatar, and then it starts to be used by historians who are writing in English from the 70s onwards. At about the time where people are becoming really interested in the conspiracy theories but also in academia people are being really interested in sort of marginal yes stories so in other words and that's it got a time i mean i know this is a strange link but that's got a tiny hint of the conspiracy theory about it in the sense that historians are sort of saying, now, the standard narrative of the great
庞塔尔（Plantard）开始——你知道的，我们在上一集里聊过这个人——开始伪造关于锡安长老会（Priory of Sion）的那些东西的时候。这是一种高档的、你知道的，学术上的等同物。法国学者开始使用“卡特里派”这个词，接着它从70年代开始被用英文写作的历史学家所采用。大约正是在这个时候，人们开始对阴谋论产生浓厚的兴趣，同时在学术界，人们也开始对边缘化的——是的——故事产生浓厚的兴趣。换句话说，这有一个时间点——我知道这听起来是一个奇怪的联系——但这带有一点点阴谋论的意味，因为历史学家们似乎在说：
and the good that you've been told all your lives is wrong, and we are uncovering hidden histories. I mean, uncovering hidden histories is what conspiracy theorists claim to do. So there is a kind of symbiosis there. Yes, but there are conspiracy theories, and the conspiracy theories are not just originating with, you know, lunatics or indeed academics in the late 20th century. Same thing, surely. It's originating from the Middle Ages themselves. Okay. So the word Cathar is being used in the Middle Ages and indeed long before the Middle Ages. So it's a Greek word.
“现在，你们一辈子听到的关于伟大与卓越的标准叙事是错误的，我们正在发掘被掩盖的历史。”我的意思是，发掘被掩盖的历史正是阴谋论者声称他们在做的事情。所以这其中存在某种共生关系。是的，但这里确实存在阴谋论，而且这些阴谋论并非仅仅源于疯子，或者20世纪末的学术界。毫无疑问，这是一回事。它源自中世纪本身。好吧。所以“卡特里派”这个词在中世纪甚至在中世纪很久以前就被使用了。所以它是一个希腊语单词。
So katharoi means the pure ones, or you might say the Puritans. So they're mentioned in a canon. So one of the kind of the statements that's issued by the Council of Nicaea, and the Council of Nicaea is convened by Constantine the Great, so the first Christian emperor. And this is, they come up with the creed, the Orthodox creed. And the Cathars are described as one of the group of heretics who are condemned. And then no one makes any more mention of them.
所以 *katharoi* 意思是“纯洁的人”，或者你也可以说就是“清教徒”（Puritans）。他们在一部教会法典中被提及——也就是尼西亚公会议（Council of Nicaea）发布的一些声明之一，而尼西亚公会议是由君士坦丁大帝（Constantine the Great）——也就是第一位基督教皇帝——召集的。这就是他们制定信经、正统信经的地方。卡特里派被描述为被谴责的异端群体之一。然后就再也没有人提起他们了。
So they vanish from the record for almost a thousand years. And then in 1163 in Cologne, six men and two women are burned as heretics and they are described as Cathars. So that is a very, very long gap. That's a huge gap. It's a huge gap. And so from that point on, in the writings of bishops and so on, you start to get mention of heretics who are called Cathars, and they're identified here and there across Christendom, never in great and then in 1173 a great council the third council to be held in the lateran palace in rome where the pope is based and you get people at
所以他们在历史记录中消失了将近一千年。然后到了1163年的科隆，有六名男子和两名女子被当作异端烧死，他们就被描述为卡特里派。所以这是一个非常非常漫长的间隔。这是一个巨大的间隔。这是一个巨大的间隔。因此从那时起，在主教们的著作等等中，你开始看到关于被称为卡特里派的异端的记载，他们在基督教世界的各处被零星地识别出来，但从未形成庞大的规模；然后到了1173年，召开了一场盛大的大公会议——即在罗马拉特兰宫（Lateran Palace）举行的第三次拉特兰公会议（Third Lateran Council），罗马是教宗的所在地——你发现来自
prelates um monks scholars coming from across europe to meet in rome and they're all bringing their reports and they're discussing heresy and they identify the existence of a single body of heretics who are in the words of one of the decrees of the Lateran Council, this third Lateran Council, whom some call Cathars, others Paterines and others by different names. So there are two obvious questions from all this. And the first is, are the Cathars who suddenly appear in Cologne in the mid 12th century, the same as the heretics condemned in the early fourth century? Because that's basically the argument that is being, you know, that is being made when you say that there is this living tradition that derives from antiquity that went underground in Byzantium, came through Bulgaria and was brought by missionaries. Which is a kind of more respectable version of the Priory of Zion or the... Exactly so. And that's what's so interesting about it. It is. And it's implausible with the
欧洲各地的神职高官、修士、学者聚集在罗马，他们都带着各自的报告，讨论异端问题，并且他们识别出了一个单一的异端团体的存在。用拉特兰公会议（这次第三次拉特兰公会议）其中一项法令的话来说：这些人“有的人称他们为卡特里派，有的人称他们为帕塔里派（Paterines），还有人称他们为其他名字”。从这一切中自然会产生两个明显的问题。第一个问题是：突然在12世纪中期出现在科隆的卡特里派，和在公元4世纪早期被谴责的异端是同一群人吗？因为这基本上就是那种观点——当你宣称存在一个源自古代、潜入拜占庭、穿过保加利亚并由传教士带来的活生生的传统时，人们所做出的论证。这可以说是锡安长老会的某种更体面的版本，或者……完全正确。这就是它最有趣的地方。确实如此。而这对于锡安长老会来说是难以置信的，
Priory of Zion. And I think it's implausible in this case. I was about to say, the answer to that question is surely no, they cannot be the same. And the other thing that you have, of course, with the Priory of Zion is this idea of a conspiracy that is not centred in one place, but spans the whole of Europe. Isaac Newton, Don Revy, Les Dawson, you know, they're all in it. You have people from, you know, you have da Vinci, Victor Hugo, Isaac Newton. Yes. So people from across Europe. And in the same way, what the prelates at the Third Lateran Council are doing are saying there is a universal church, that all of these heretics are joined. I mean, again, it seems improbable. It seems much likelier that this is something that is being projected.
我认为在这个案例中同样难以置信。我正要说的是，这个问题的答案绝对是否定的，他们不可能是同一群人。当然，你关于锡安长老会所面临的另一个问题是，这种阴谋论的中心不在一个地方，而是横跨整个欧洲。艾萨克·牛顿、唐·雷维（Don Revy）、莱斯·道森（Les Dawson）——你知道的，他们全都在里面。你拥有来自——你知道的，你有达芬奇、维克多·Hugo、艾萨克·牛顿。是的。所以是来自欧洲各地的人。同样地，第三次拉特兰公会议上的高级神职人员们所做的，就是声称存在一个普遍的教会，所有的这些异端都是联合在一起的。我的意思是，这同样显得不大可能。看起来更有可能的是，这是一种被投射出来的东西。
Yes. So when all these people meet up in the Lateran Council, they're all comparing notes and they'll go, yeah, they're all part of the same organisation. But it's actually very clear that there is confusion among the accusers as to who or what Cathars are. So there is a German monk who claims that their name derives from the cat that devotees of Satan were reputed to kiss on its anus. Oh my word. Yeah. So you become a worshipper of satan and you you kiss the bottom of a cat a great black cat are people doing that in large numbers i don't believe it i think it's improbable and so the implication of that is that actually the the cathars are so obscure that only
是的。所以当所有这些人聚集在拉特兰公会议上时，他们都在互相核对笔记，然后会说：“对，他们都属于同一个组织。”但实际上非常清楚的是，指控者们对于卡特里派究竟是谁、究竟是什么东西，其实充满了困惑。有一个德国修士声称，他们的名字来源于魔鬼信徒们传说中会去亲吻肛门的猫。哦，天哪。是的。所以你成了魔鬼崇拜者，然后去亲吻一只猫的屁股，一只巨大的黑猫。人们会大规模地做这种事吗？我不相信，我觉得这不大可能。所以其中的含义其实是，卡特里派是如此晦涩难懂，以至于只有
the very very learned know who they are and the antiquity of them is the point so by kind of name-checking cathars you are showing off how how intellectual you are how learned you are how scholarly you are yeah and this this period the 12th century is when universities are starting to appear so this is where you get people whose job it is basically to sit in universities and study this stuff and suddenly they're saying you know they're reading up about the Cathars in ancient tomes and suddenly they're discovering them, you know, on the Rhine or in Northern Italy or whatever.
非常非常博学的人才知道他们是谁，而他们的古老性正是关键所在。因此，通过顺便提及卡特里派，你是在炫耀自己有多么有知识、多么博学、多么学术。是的，而这个时期——12世纪，正是大学开始出现的时候。所以正是在这里，你拥有了这样一群人：他们的工作基本上就是坐在大学里研究这些东西，然后突然之间，他们说——你知道的，他们在古代典籍中阅读关于卡特里派的内容，然后突然在莱茵河畔、意大利北部或其他什么地方发现了他们。
And what is even better, Tom, is that they are saying, well, it's very complicated to explain. If you know, you know, and if you don't know, well, you're obviously not intelligent enough to understand. Yeah. So basically what is it? It's the kind of, you know, it's the literate elite, the scholarly elite, university educated people who are basically constructing the idea of a universal heretical church that spans Christendom and reaches back to the distant mists of the church's beginnings. And it seems likelier that
而且更妙的是，汤姆，他们会说：“嗯，这解释起来非常复杂。如果你懂，你自然懂；如果你不懂，好吧，那你显然没有足够的智力去理解。”是的。所以基本上这到底是什么？它就是那种——你知道的，识字的精英、学术精英、受过大学教育的人，他们基本上构建了这样一个概念：存在一个横跨基督教世界、并一直追溯到教会创立之初的遥远迷雾中的普遍异端教会。而看起来更有可能是
they are making it up than that this this church actually exists right so in other words it's it's you know like all conspiracy theories it's telling you less about what is actually happening than about the people who are coming who are bringing it up okay so tell us about the people who are bringing it up then so these are these are people who want to see themselves as the representatives of a completely unchanging church so the catholic church is something that has existed since the time of christ it's unchanging it embodies eternal doctrines internal teachings eternal truths and convers its enemy, the shadow of heresy, likewise, is something unchanging and something universal. However, the fact is that for most of
他们在凭空捏造，而不是这个教会真的存在。对吧？换句话说，正如所有阴谋论一样，它与其说告诉你实际发生了什么，不如说告诉你那些提出这一说法的人是什么样的人。好吧，那就给我们讲讲那些提出这一说法的人吧。这些人是想要将自己视为一个完全一成不变的教会的代表。因为天主教会是一个自基督时代以来就一直存在的事物，它是一成不变的，它体现了永恒的教条、永恒的教导、永恒的真理；而与它相对的敌人——异端的阴影，同样也是一成不变、普遍存在的。然而事实是，在大部分
the early Middle Ages, the church is not going after heretics. There are no heretics. And they start to appear in the 11th century. Suddenly, in the 11th century, charges of heresy are starting to be brought, and people in the church are starting to become worried about heresy. And what is the process, you know, what is happening that is making this change happen? And the irony is, as I said at the end of the last episode, that there are Cathars, and they're in full view. The Cathars are the people who have taken charge of the commanding heights of the Catholic Church, because a Cathar is someone who is, you know, said it's a Puritan, someone who wants to be pure. And this in the 11th century becomes the great goal, the great object of reformers in the Catholic Church, that they want to cleanse and purify the whole fabric of Christendom, of the taint of sin. That it's not just individual believers, you have to be baptised and washed clean. The whole fabric of Christendom does. And this desire to cleanse and purify Christendom, it's a kind of progressive ambition to make the
中世纪早期，教会并没有去追捕异端。根本没有异端。他们是在11世纪开始出现的。突然之间，在11世纪，关于异端的指控开始被提出，教会里的人也开始对异端感到担忧。那么这个过程是怎样的——你知道的，究竟发生了什么才促成了这种转变？而讽刺的是，正如我在上一集结束时所说的那样，卡特里派确实存在，而且他们就在显眼的地方。卡特里派就是那些掌控了天主教会至高权力的人，因为卡特里派的意思就是——正如前面所说，是一个清教徒，一个想要变得纯洁的人。而这在11世纪成为了天主教会改革派的伟大目标和宏伟宗旨：他们想要洗刷和纯净整个基督教世界的罪恶之污。不仅仅是个别信徒需要受洗并被洗净，整个基督教世界都需要。而这种想要清洗和纯净基督教世界的渴望，是一种激进的雄心，旨在让
Christian people better, nobler, to fulfill God's purpose more completely. In the 11th century, this precipitates what R.I. Moore, Bob Moore, who I mentioned, written this great book, The War on Heresy, describes as Europe's first revolution. And it's a revolution that it's called either the papal revolution or the Gregorian revolution after the Pope Gregory VII, who is most kind of closely associated with this process. And it's an incredibly convulsive experience, not just for the church, but for the whole of Europe, because it requires people who are reluctant to accept this kind of campaigning idea that the whole of Christendom should be transformed and cleansed. It requires them to
基督教人民变得更好、更高尚，更彻底地实现上帝的旨意。在11世纪，这催生了R·I·摩尔——也就是我提到的写了这本伟大的书《反异端战争》的鲍勃·摩尔——所描述的“欧洲第一次革命”。这场革命被称为教宗革命（Papal Revolution）或格里高利革命（Gregorian Revolution），是以与这一进程关系最为密切的教宗格里高利七世（Gregory VII）的名字命名的。这是一段极其动荡的经历，不仅对教会而言，对整个欧洲来说都是如此，因为它要求那些不愿接受这种变革理念的人——即整个基督教世界都应被转化和清洗的理念——
be kind of whipped into shape. So that famously includes kings and emperors so gregory the seventh you know he he has the emperor himself henry the fourth kneel in the snows beneath his castle at canossa and beg for forgiveness and this kind of great convulsive process whereby the roman church is trying to break the power of kings to essentially appropriate everything that is the dimension of the supernatural into their own hands. And this is the kind of the process that results in universities, because you need kind of literate, clerical people who can articulate and carry through the ambitions of this revolutionary program. And that's how universities, you know, Bologna or Oxford or whatever. So Bologna, the first one, it begins as a kind of great centre of legal students because they're trying to construct frameworks of law that can govern this new kind of Christian understanding of what the Christian world should be.
必须被“整顿到位”。所以其中最著名的就包括国王和皇帝。因此格里高利七世——你知道的，他曾让皇帝亨利四世（Henry IV）本人跪在卡诺萨（Canossa）城堡下的雪地里祈求宽恕。这种巨大的动荡过程，使得罗马教会试图打破国王的权力，本质上将所有超自然维度的权力抓在自己手中。而这正是催生大学的过程，因为你需要那些识字的、神职人员背景的人，来阐述和执行这一革命纲领的雄心。这就是大学——你知道的，博洛尼亚或牛津等大学——是如何诞生的。因此博洛尼亚作为第一所大学，最初是作为法学学生的伟大中心起步的，因为他们正试图构建能够管理这种关于基督教世界应该是什么样的新理解的法律框架。
And also it generates what will come to be called crusades because the church needs defenders and it needs to propagate. It's, you know, it's a missionary faith, like all the revolutions that will follow it. It believes in the totality of its vision and it needs to be propagated if needs be at the point of a sword. And so it's a very, very convulsive experience, a transformative experience. It's the primal experience of revolution in European history. And, you. And it's not Lenin or Rose Pierre or Luther who stands at the primal head of the revolutionary tradition in Europe. It's Gregory VII and the reformers around him. These are the primal revolutionaries. So the Catholic Church in the 11th, 12th, 13th century, in the period that we're talking about, when the Cathars are supposed to have existed, this is a revolutionary institution. But from above.
这也催生了后来被称为十字军东征的事物，因为教会需要捍卫者，它需要传播信仰。它是一种传教信仰，就像所有随后的革命一样。它坚信自己愿景的总体性，如果有必要，必须以剑刃来传播。所以这是一段非常非常动荡的经历，一段具有变革性的经历。它是欧洲历史上革命的原始体验。而且，你。而且站在欧洲革命传统最前沿的，不是列宁、罗伯斯庇尔或路德，而是格里高利七世和围绕在他身边的改革派。这些人才是最初的革命者。所以在11、12、13世纪的天主教会——在我们正在讨论的这个卡特里派本应存在的时期——这是一个革命性的机构。但它是自上而下的。
Absolutely. A bit like, it's a stupid comparison, but Mao's Cultural Revolution or something. A revolution. Kind of above and kind of not. And this is where we get back to heresy and the Cathars. So you remember in the Third Lateran Council, 1173, you get this description of heretics whom some call Cathars, others Paterines, and others by different names. So who are the Paterines? So the Paterines take us exactly to all the ambivalences and complexities of this process. So the Paterines are radical Christians in radical Christians in Milan in the mid 11th century who are basically street reformers. They are people who are opposed to the bishop of Milan own poverty, their ascetic, and they're vigorously insistent that
绝对是的。有点像——虽然这是一个愚蠢的比较——毛泽东的文化大革命或类似的东西。一场革命。某种程度上自上而下，又某种程度上并非如此。而正是在这里，我们回到了异端和卡特里派的话题。所以你还记得在1173年的第三次拉特兰公会议上，有这样一段对异端的描述：“有的人称他们为卡特里派，有的人称他们为帕塔里派，还有人称他们为其他名字”。那么帕塔里派是谁呢？所以帕塔里派带我们直接深入到了这一进程的所有矛盾与复杂性之中。帕塔里派是11世纪中期米兰的激进基督徒——
the bishop and his clergy should be celibate, that celibacy should be the marker of their purity, of the fact that they are becoming, you know, Catharoi, Cathars. And this is exactly what Gregory VII, as he will become, Hildebrand, as he was called at this point. This is what he wants as well. And so basically, he forms an alliance with these patterines. Patterine comes from the name of the rag market in Milan. These are people who are absolutely from the streets, but it's an alliance of the top and the bottom for the would-be reformers in Rome with these kind of street reformers in Milan. And they are, you know, these violent demands that priests set themselves apart from the laity, that they do that through
激进的基督徒，他们基本上是街头改革派。他们是一群反对米兰主教的人，主张贫穷，实行苦行，并且极力坚持认为：主教和他的神职人员应当独身，独身应当成为他们纯洁的标志，成为他们正在成为——你知道的，*Catharoi*，即卡特里派——的标志。而这正是后来成为格里高利七世的希ildebrand（当时被称为希ildebrand）所渴望的。这也是他想要的。所以基本上，他与这些帕塔里派结成了同盟。帕塔里派这个名字来源于米兰的旧布市场。这些人绝对来自底层街头，但这是高层与底层的同盟：罗马的准改革派与米兰的这些街头改革派结成了同盟。他们提出——
rejecting sex, through casting aside their concubines, all these kinds of things. And Gregory goes into alliance with them, the reformers go into alliance with them, because it's their ambition to kind of undermine the legitimacy of bishops and clergy who are opposing them. So they're using these people to kind of break. against the people in the middle. Yes, and for reasons that perhaps, you know, at the end of this series you might touch on as to where exactly all this ends up. So this is going on in the 11th century. It's this kind of process whereby the papal reformers are in alliance with very radical Christians, Christians who see priests as corrupt,
这些激烈的要求，即神职人员必须将自己与平民区分开来，必须通过拒绝性行为、抛弃他们的情妇来做到这一点，所有诸如此类的事情。格里高利与他们结盟，改革派与他们结盟，因为他们的雄心是要削弱那些反对他们的主教和神职人员的合法性。所以他们利用这些人来打破中间派的抵抗。是的。出于这样的原因——或许，你知道的，在本系列结束时你可能会提及这一切最终究竟通向何方。所以这发生在11世纪。这是一种这样的进程：教皇改革派与非常激进的基督徒结盟——这些基督徒视神职人员为腐败，拥抱贫穷，拥抱贞洁，在田野里、在街头展现某种神迹——并被人们赞誉为在教会体制之外因其圣洁而受到崇敬的人。但到了12世纪，革命开始取得成功。因此，改革派已经开始掌控那些他们此前一直在忙于破坏的机构。所以现在，既然他们已经掌控了主教职位，既然他们已经强迫神职人员实行独身，既然他们已经设法让国王和皇帝接受了这种新体制，那么神职人员、主教和神父的权威就变得非常重要了。
who are embracing poverty, embracing chastity, performing kind of miracles, you know, out in the fields, out are embracing poverty, embracing chastity, performing kind of miracles, you know, out in the fields, out in the streets, and who are being hailed as people, you know, for their holiness outside the structures of the church. But by the 12th century, the revolution is starting to succeed. And so the reformers have begun to capture the institutions that previously they'd been busy undermining. And so now, now that they have captured the bishoprics, now that they've enforced chastity on the clergy, now that they're kind of managing to get kings and emperors to accept this kind of new dispensation, now the authority of the clergy and the bishops and the priests is really important.
因此，帕塔里派现在成了一个问题。所以他们——你知道的，在11世纪时他们曾是有用的，但现在他们成了一个问题。因此，你知道的，到了12世纪末，他们被指控为异端。所以12世纪以及在12世纪被称为异端的事物的涌现方式，实际上反映了我们在自那以后发生的每一次革命中都能看到的一种现象：一旦革命精英夺取了至高无上的权力并基本上成为了新精英——是的，成为了新当权派——那么他们总是要面对两大类反对者。其中之一就是那些认为革命还不够彻底的人——也就是激进派，帕塔里派就是一个例子，他们认为仍然存在腐败，神父们仍然需要被监督。所以他们是一个问题。当然，另一群反对者，则是那些被时代抛在后面的人。
And so the patrines now have become a problem. And so they, you know, in the 11th century, they'd been useful, but now they've become a problem. And so, you know, by the end of the 12th century, they're being identified as heretics. So the 12th century and the way in which heresy, what is called heresy, emerges in the 12th century is actually a reflection of something that we see in every revolution that has happened since which is that once revolutionary elites have seized control of the commanding heights and and basically become the new elite yes the new establishment then they they always face two blocks of opponents and one of those is those who think the revolution hasn't gone far enough so the extremists the military extremists of whom the patrines would be an example
用希拉里·克林顿的话说，就是“可悲的人”（deplorables）。是的。没错，就是那些乡巴佬（gamins）。乡巴佬。没错，就是乡巴佬。
the fact that you know there's still corruption the priests still need to be kept on their toes. So they are a problem. And of course, the other people, the block of people, are those who've been left behind. What Hillary Clinton might call the deplorables. Yes. Right, the gamins. The gamins. Exactly, the gamins.
所以这就是为什么在11世纪和12世纪会出现异端高涨的原因：因为教会才是那个激进的革命机构，但它正在重新定义它的反对者——无论是那些觉得革命还不够彻底的人，还是那些被抛在后面的人——将他们打成异端。没错。是的。既然你们有了这些最初为了研究法律而建立、但逐渐转向巴黎和牛津等地的大学，它们正在为这个更加体制化的世界培养神职人员，在这个世界里，教会的权力要连贯得多，国王也需要神职人员等等。所以你有了越来越多熟悉教父著作和教会法典等资料的人。因此，他们开始回顾教会的早期历史，寻找异端的原型。而他们在那里找到的是二元论者、诺斯替派（Gnostics）、卡特里派以及所有这些形形色色的人。因此，他们越是寻找这些人，他们就越是自己吓唬自己，他们也就越发焦虑地认为，这些所谓的古代异端真实存在，他们的教导与古代异端一脉相承，并且是一个普遍的教会。他们对此变得越来越偏执。所以最初在11和12世纪，教会对待
And so this is why you have an upsurge of heresy in the 11th and the 12th century, is that it's the church that is the radical and the revolutionary institution, but it is redefining its opponents, both those who feel that the revolution hasn't gone far enough and those who've been left behind as heretics. Right. Yes. And so since you're having these universities that initially are being set up to study law, but increasingly they move to Paris and Oxford and so on, they are they're kind of preparing clerics for this much more kind of institutionalized world where the power of the church is much, much more coherent and kings need clerics and all this kind of stuff. So you're having more and more people who are familiar with the writings of the church fathers and the canons of the church and so on. And so they are looking back to the early history of the church for archetypes of heresy. And what they're finding there are dualists and Gnostics and Cathars and all these kinds of various people. And so the more they're looking for them, the more they spook themselves, and the more anxious they become about the existence of these supposedly ancient heretics who derive their teachings from, you know, in a lineal descent from ancient heretics and are a kind of universal church. They become more and more kind of paranoid about it. And so initially, in the 11th and 12th centuries, the church approached
异端的方式非常小心翼翼，因为有点像17世纪的猎巫人——你知道的，他们意识到相关的证据往往很难确凿查实，而且他们对此也并非完全确定。但到了第三次拉特兰公会议时，它开始将卡特里派和帕塔里派识别为一个普遍的教会，他们变得积极主动得多了。因此在1184年，你获得了一项教皇法令，要求主教们不仅要等待针对异端的指控，还要主动出去寻找他们，把他们嗅出来，把他们追捕归案。而与这一发展最具重大意义的关联人物，也许是所有中世纪教皇中最伟大的一位，当然也是最有权势的一位：这位将英格兰置于禁令之下、革除约翰（John）教籍的教皇，名叫英诺森三世（Innocent III）。他在位的时间是从1198年一直到1216年。换句话说，正是在这段时期，针对朗格多克所谓异端的十字军东征将被发起。英诺森三世——他将自己描述为“在上帝之下，但在人类之上；小于上帝，但大于人类；审判一切事物，却不受任何人审判”。他痴迷于两件事：他痴迷于卡特里派，他总是喋喋不休地谈论他们，他担心卡特里派无处不在、正在滋生。所以从两个方面来看，汤姆，他很像你。在什么方面？自我感觉良好？不，那不是我。他觉得自己高人一等，不受任何人审判，而且痴迷于卡特里派。你多年来一直想做这个播客。是的，我确实想。好吧，那么在对卡特里派的痴迷这一点上，我承认这一点。
heretics in a kind of very gingery way, because a bit like witchcraft hunters in the 17th century, you know, they're aware that the evidence for it is often quite difficult to pin down, and they're not kind of entirely certain about it. But by the time you have this third Lateran Council, where it's, you know, identifying Cathars and Patarines as a kind of universal church, they're becoming much more proactive. So in 1184, you get a papal decree that requires bishops not just to wait for accusations against heretics, but actually to go out and look for them, to kind of sniff them out, to hunt them down. And the figure who is most momentously associated with this development is perhaps the greatest of all the medieval popes, certainly the most powerful. The pope who places England under interdiction, you know, excommunicates John, a pope called Innocent III. And he is pope from 1198 through to 1216. So in other words, the period when the crusade
所以他痴迷于卡特里派，尤其是在意大利北部，但他发现他们无处不在。但另一件让他痴迷的事情，是朗格多克（法国南部）地区存在的特殊异端威胁。或许我们应该在这个时候休息一下。等我们回来后，我们可以探讨为什么英诺森三世会认为那个地区……但在我们这样做之前，我要直言不讳地说出来：我知道每个人都会以为
against the supposed heretics in the Lankadok will be launched. And Innocent III, so he describes himself as below God, but above man, less than God, but greater than man, who judges all things, but who no one judges. And he is obsessed by two things he's obsessed by cathars he's always going on about them he's worried that cathars are everywhere kind of breeding so in two respects tom he's like you in what way high opinion of himself no that's not me thinks he's above other people but no one judges and obsessed by cathars you've been trying to you've been wanting to do this podcast for years yeah i have okay so in the obsession with cathars i accept that.
我会这么想，我确实也在这么想。这一切与——以一个首席“乡巴佬”的身份发言——你知道的，嗯，是的，与当下的文化战争之间，存在着如此多的共鸣，不是吗？我的意思是，当你刚才在讲的时候，我脑子里一直在想：“噢天哪，这简直就是国民托管组织（National Trust）。”所以——或许我们可以在本系列结束时，探讨一下这些共鸣。太棒了。但目前为止，我们还是留在朗格多克吧。别担心，休息过后，我们将在朗格多克的城堡和所有这些事物中归来。获取现场门票，请前往 therestis entertainment.com，也就是 therestis entertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，本期节目由著名历史学家汤姆·霍兰以及身为顶级阿尔比修士的我——多米尼克·桑布拉为您主持。如果你还没有听过我们上一期关于《达芬奇密码》的播客，
So he's obsessed by Cathars, particularly in Northern Italy, but he's seeing them everywhere. But the other thing he's obsessed by, particular threat of heresy in the Languedoc, in the south of France. And perhaps we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we can explore why innocent the third thinks that that that region but before we do that i'm just going to come out and say it i know everybody thinks
那这听起来就会是一堆毫无意义的胡言乱语，但愿你们都听过了。汤姆，我觉得那段内容简直太迷人了。这对我来说完全是一个全新的启示，特别是关于教皇革命以及异端甚至卡特里派概念的创造的所有那些内容。但是，为什么偏偏是法国西南部呢？我的意思是，按照13世纪早期欧洲的标准，以及天主教会（罗马教会）的标准，那个地区确实存在大量的异端。而原因就在于我们在第一集里提到过的事实：即这个地区距离权力中心相当遥远，而且地势相当崎岖。所以你想想那些卡特里派的城堡，它们是建立在——你知道的——突出的岩石等等之上的，田地则围绕在它们周围，被非常费力地耕种着。所以这里相当偏远——它是落后地区，它是那种——即便在现在也会投票支持脱欧或支持特朗普之类的地方。我的意思是，
that i'm going to be thinking it i am thinking it there are so many resonances aren't there between all this and uh speaking as a speaking as a chief gammon you know well yeah and the culture wars of the present moment i can i mean when you were talking i was just thinking oh my god it's the national trust well so so perhaps we could at the end of this this series we could we could look at that those resonances brilliant but for the time being we will we'll stay in the long dock don't worry uh we were back in the long dock amid the castles and all that stuff after the break. access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history with a renowned historian uh tom holland and top albino monk me dominic zambra if you haven't listened to our previous podcast in the da vinci code that
那是——是的，我猜他们现在会投票给国民阵线（National Front）吧？我不知道。我不知道他们现在是否会投票给国民阵线，但我可以说的是，你现在去朗格多克，其中一些村庄非常贫困，你知道的，它们距离任何大都市中心都感觉十万八千里。所以你完全可以理解，回到12世纪或任何时候、13世纪，这些地方正是教皇革命——那种法律主义的、由大学驱动的革命——尚未触及的地方。绝对如此。因此，法国的大大学显然在巴黎，而巴黎距离那里非常非常遥远。所以所有那些学者、所有那些受过大学教育的人——他们随后去——你知道的——充实教廷（Curia，教皇宫廷），并为天主教会庞大的官僚机构提供律师、官僚、教师等等——他们认为自己体现了教会的普遍真理是理所当然的，尽管实际上他们才是真正的革命者。所以他们忘记了这样一个事实：你知道的，正是他们在搞创新。
will just be meaningless babble but let's hope that you have. Tom, so that I thought that was absolutely fascinating. And it was a complete revelation to me, actually, all that stuff about the sort of papal revolution and the creation of the idea of heretics and indeed Cathars. But why the southwest of France in particular? I mean, by the standards of early 13th century Europe, that there is, and by the standards of the Catholic Church, the Roman Church, there is a lot of heresy in the region. And the reason for that is the fact that we mentioned in the first episode, namely that this area is kind of quite remote from the centres of power, and it's quite rugged. And so you think of all those Cathar castles, they're kind built on you know outcrops of rock and so on and the fields are kind of gathered around them and they're very heavily worked so this is quite a long way you know it's it's the backwards it's it's the kind of areas well even now voted brexit or for trump or whatever i mean
只会是毫无意义的废话，但希望你也有同感。汤姆，所以我觉得那真的非常迷人。对我来说这其实是一个全新的启示，关于那场教皇革命、异端概念的产生以及实际上还有卡特派的种种。但为什么偏偏是法国西南部？我的意思是，以13世纪初欧洲的标准来看，以天主教会、罗马教会的标准来看，那个地区的异端实在太多了。原因正如我们在第一集里提到过的那样，这个地区距离权力中心相当遥远，而且地势相当崎岖。所以你想想那些卡特派的城堡，它们基本上是建在你知道的岩石露头上之类的地方，田地就在它们周围聚集，耕作强度非常大，所以这相当于是个很远的地方，你知道的，这是个偏远落后地区，是那种甚至到现在还会投票支持脱欧、支持特朗普之类的地方，我的意思是
that's yeah i guess vote for the National Front now, do they? I don't know. I don't know if they vote for the National Front now, but what I will say is you go to the Long Dot now, and some of those villages are very poor, are very, you know, they fill an awful long way from any metropolitan centres. So you can completely see how going back to the 12th century or whenever, 13th century, they would be places that the papal
没错，我猜他们现在会投票支持国民阵线吧？我不知道。我不知道他们现在是不是投票支持国民阵线，但我能说的是，你现在去朗格多克，其中一些村庄非常穷，非常……你知道的，它们距离任何大都市中心都非常遥远。所以你完全可以理解，回到12世纪或别的什么时期、13世纪，那里会成为教皇……
revolution, the legalistic university-driven revolution, has not yet reached. Exactly. So the great university in France is obviously in Paris, and Paris is a very, very long way. So all those scholars, all those university-educated people who are then going on to, you know, staff the Curia, the papal court, and to provide the vast bureaucracy of the Catholic Church with its, you know, its lawyers, its bureaucrats, its teachers, and so on. They take for granted that they embody the universal truths of the church, even though they are actually the revolutionaries. So they forget the fact that, you know, they're the ones who were doing the innovations.
革命，那个法学驱动、以大学为核心的革命，尚未触及的地方。没错。所以法国伟大的大学显然在巴黎，而巴黎非常、非常遥远。因此，所有那些学者、所有那些受过大学教育的人，他们后来去……你知道的，在教廷、教皇法院中供职，并为天主机构庞大的官僚体系提供……你知道的，它的律师、官僚、教师等等。他们理所当然地认为自己体现了教会的普遍真理，尽管他们实际上才是革命者。所以他们忘记了这样一个事实，你知道的，他们才是那些进行创新的人。
Right. We're not the cultural warriors. You're the cultural warriors. It's exactly that. It's exactly that. It's exactly that. So, yeah, kind of wonderfully, yes. And so it's the regions that are kind of beyond the remit of the church authorities, beyond the remit of bishops and universities and teachers and bureaucrats and so on, who are seen as, you know, why are they holding on to these ludicrous beliefs? Exactly. There are people who are saying, but I just think what everybody thought yesterday. No, no, no, no, no. So this is now a kind of heresy. And so it's this region between, I guess, the Rhône and the Dordogne in southern France comes to be seen as heaving full of kind of backwards people who don't use pronouns and have very unsound views of trans rights and all
对的。我们不是文化战士。你们才是文化战士。就是这样。完全是这样。完全是这样。所以，是的，某种程度上奇妙的是，确实如此。因此，这些地区超出了教会当局的管辖范围，超出了主教、大学、教师、官僚等人的管辖范围，他们被视为，你知道的，为什么他们还要坚持这些荒谬的信仰？没错。有些人会说，但我只是在想昨天所有人都在想的事。不，不，不，不，不。所以这现在成了一种异端。因此，这个介于罗讷河和多尔多涅河之间的地区，在法国南部，开始被视为充满了一种落后的人，他们不使用代词，对跨性别权益有非常不健全的看法，以及所有
that. They're the equivalent of that. They love flags and statues. Exactly. Flag shaggers. So the Third Lateran Council, where you had this thing about Patrines and Cathars, it actually specifies that the lands around Albi and Toulouse. So Toulouse is the great city of the region. Albi, we mentioned it in the previous episode, is the, it's the southernmost bishopric of the southernmost archbishopric in France. As,
诸如此类的事。他们就是这种人的代名词。他们热爱旗帜和雕像。没错。旗帜狂热者。因此，在第三拉特兰会议上，你遇到了关于帕特里派和卡特里派的事情，它实际上具体指出了阿尔比和图卢兹周围的土地。所以图卢兹是该地区伟大的城市。阿尔比，我们在上一集中提到过，是法国最南端总教区最南端的主教辖区，作为
as being a particularly kind of noxious breeding ground for heretics. And you get abbots and papal legates kind of visiting the region and they're appalled by it so it's kind of like you know people come to chipping norton or deeds well actually maybe it's made by people go to it's actually what it is it's when the guardian sends people out to hull to find out what people are thinking yes listen to gammon's gammon's in pubs in the aftermath of brexit they will send people to the north of england and come back absolutely appalled by what they... Yeah. And what they find there is that the people in this region dislike the kind of, you know, the representatives of this papal revolution as outsiders.
一个滋生异端的特别有害的温床。你会看到修道院院长和教皇使节访问该地区，他们对此感到震惊，所以这有点像，你知道的，人们来到奇平诺顿或者迪兹，哦其实也许是由人们去的地方决定的，实际上它是这样的，当卫报派人去赫尔了解人们的想法时，是的，听听英国脱欧后酒吧里的加蒙人，他们会派人去英格兰北部，回来后对他们所...是的。而他们在那里发现的是，该地区的人们不喜欢这种，你知道的，作为外来者的教皇革命的代表。
They kind of dismiss the whole idea of reformatio, of reformation, of, you know this idea that christendom can should be purified and reformed and and and all that they dispute the claim to authority of of the pope's kind of into you know international apparatus of of uh of control its demands that that everybody you know all christians should should do what the papacy says, the deference that they demand, the tithes that they're obliged to pay, the services that they're meant to go to, all this kind of stuff. And also they dispute the idea that there is some kind of fundamental division between priests and the laity. So that was kind of what the Patrines were targeting, because they felt that because the Bishop of Milan and his clergy had concubines, therefore, they were not pure.
他们有点不屑一顾，不接受改革（reformatio）、宗教改革的整个理念，你知道的，这种基督教世界可以而且应该被净化、改革等等的理念，他们对教皇那种国际控制机构、关于其要求的权威提出质疑，即每个人，你知道的，所有的基督徒都应该听从教皇的旨意，他们所要求的顺从，他们被迫支付的什一税，他们应该去参加的礼拜，所有这些类似的东西。而且他们还反驳了神职人员和俗人之间存在某种根本分歧的观点。所以这正是帕特里派所针对的，因为他们觉得米兰主教和他的神职人员有情妇，因此，他们并不纯洁。
They were not separate. You know, like they weren't Cathars. They hadn't separated themselves from the mass of the laity. But this in around Toulouse, around Albi, this is seen as something that's absolutely fine, because it had always been fine. You know, that had always been the way it had been. So the priests and the people are very, they're not distinguishable in a way in that area. And so the heretics in this region, you know, they're not called Cathars. They're called Boni homines in Latin, which can mean both good men and good women.
他们没有分离开来。你知道的，就像他们不是卡特里派一样。他们没有把自己从广大俗人群体中分离出来。但这在图卢兹周围，在阿尔比周围，被视为完全没问题的事情，因为它一直都没问题。你知道的，事情本来就是这样的。所以神职人员和普通百姓非常亲近，在那个地区某种程度上是分不清的。因此，该地区的异端分子，你知道的，他们不被称为卡特里派。他们在拉丁语中被称为“善良的人”（Boni homines），既可以指好男人，也可以指好女人。
And you have this idea that holiness is not only to be found in priests that actually you know members of the laity can be at least if not more holy than priests yeah and so you have men are holy if they display courtesy because this is a very very intense competitive world um where people are scratching a living from very poor soil often. And they're kind of living cheek by jowl. And so structures of courtesy have evolved that enable order to be kept. And this is the world of the troubadours. You know, they celebrate people who are models of good manners yeah who behave well and these models
并且你有这样一种观点，即圣洁不仅仅存在于神职人员身上，实际上，你知道的，俗人成员可以至少和神职人员一样圣洁，甚至更圣洁，是的，所以你会有这样的看法：如果人们表现出礼貌，他们就是圣洁的，因为这是一个非常非常激烈、充满竞争的世界，人们经常在非常贫瘠的土地上艰难谋生。他们生活得息息相关。因此，为了维持秩序，演化出了礼貌的结构。这就是特罗巴杜（游吟诗人）的世界。你知道的，他们赞美那些举止优雅的模范，是的，他们行为端正，而这些模范
of courtesy of good behavior are seen by people in the region as being overtly christian models that they are that they enable you to be holy so you know a man who is who is a kind of you know a model of courtesy a model of self-restraint he's a good man by virtue of that right and likewise women also can win this status but very particular types of so so prepubescent girls and women who have been married and have gone through the menopause so they can so they can be good women so it's basically chastity to some degree is it yes essentially yeah but it's people who who who cannot yeah yeah i mean basically it's basically chastity to some degree is it yes essentially yeah but it's people who who who cannot yeah yeah i mean basically it's people who are outside the cycles of of sex and marriage and childbirth yeah and the very holiest are believed you know that you can attain um you
这种礼貌、良好行为的模范被该地区的人们视为公开的基督教模范，他们认为这些模范能让你变得圣洁，所以你知道的，一个展现礼貌、展现自我克制模范的男人，凭此他就是一个好人，对吧。同样地，女性也可以赢得这种地位，但必须是特定类型的女性，比如未成年女孩和已经结婚并经历过更年期的女性，这样她们才能成为好女人，所以这基本上在某种程度上就是贞洁，对吗？是的，本质上是的，但它是指那些无法，是的，我的意思是，基本上在某种程度上就是贞洁，对吗？是的，本质上是的，但它是指那些无法，是的，我的意思是，基本上它是指那些处于性、婚姻和生育周期之外的人，是的，而且人们认为最圣洁的人，你知道的，你可以达到
can approach the perfection of christ this is a kind of great dream identification with with with the figure of christ and that therefore the divine is manifest in the everyday so that is a bit like the the stereotypical view of the cathars the sort of slightly conspiracy theory view that they have a horror of sex or whatever and the horror of the material world they don't have a horror of it they don't have a horror of it they don't have a horror of it but i think the the the idea that these good men who basically, you know, they hold views on church doctrine that are kind of both distinctively their own. So in some ways they are heretical. They seem to have downplayed the significance of the Old Testament, for instance, to have only valued certain books of the bible and these kind of heresies when they're debated you know so you get uh scholars and monks going in there and debating with the good men and they're often kind of appalled by what seems to them overtly heretical statements but at the same time the good men are capable of giving perfectly orthodox summations of christian doctrine so it's
你可以接近基督的完美，这是一种伟大的梦想，与基督的形象融为一体，因此神圣性体现在日常生活之中，所以这有点像对卡特里派的刻板印象，那种略带阴谋论的观点，即他们对性或诸如此类的事情感到恐惧，对物质世界感到恐惧，他们并不害怕，他们并不害怕，他们并不害怕，但我认为，这些好人的观点，基本上，你知道的，他们对教会教义的看法既有其独特的个性。所以在某些方面他们是异端的。例如，他们似乎贬低了旧约的重要性，只重视圣经的某些书卷，当这些异端邪说被辩论时，你知道的，你会让学者和僧侣去那里与好人辩论，他们经常对他们看来公开的异端言论感到震惊，但与此同时，好人能够对基督教教义做出完全正统的总结，所以它
it's it's not kind of radically radically unorthodox it's a question of what they're emphasizing rather question what they're emphasizing and there are you know there are lots of people so a lot of say the lords the ladies in the region you know they're aware of what's going on in the broader world they are orthodox catholics but they don't feel obliged to go after the good men and the people who regard them as holy because the divisions between them aren't that great. You know, it's just kind of shades of difference. They're not that great. But what starts to kind of entrench the divisions, it's not just that the people from outside, the papal legates and so on, the monks who are coming in
它并非那种根本上的、彻底的异端，这是一个他们强调什么的问题，更确切地说是他们强调什么的问题，而且有（你知道的）很多人，所以该地区的很多领主、贵族，你知道的，他们了解更广阔世界里发生的事情，他们是正统的天主教徒，但他们并不觉得有义务去追捕好人和那些视他们为圣人的人，因为他们之间的分歧并没有那么大。你知道的，这只是一种微小的差异。分歧没有那么大。但是，开始加深这种分歧的，不仅仅是来自外部的人——教皇使节等等，那些前来这里的僧侣
are appalled and start seeing heresy. It's also the fact that the good men, as they feel themselves being the objects of the contempt of the outsiders, start to see the outsiders as the heretics. And so, for instance, you have a bishop who overtly denounces them as heretics. And the reply of the good men is that it's not they who are heretical, but the bishop who pronounced judgment upon them. And they describe him as a ravening wolf, a hypocrite, and a foe of God. And his judgment is dishonest. So now the culture war is raging in earnest. So it is a culture. You could describe it as a culture war.
感到震惊并开始视其为异端。这也是因为好人们在感到自己成为外来者蔑视的对象时，开始将外来者视为异端。因此，举例来说，有一位主教公开谴责他们为异端。而好人们的回答是，异端的不是他们，而是对他们做出判决的主教。他们将他描述为一头凶残的狼、一个伪君子和上帝的敌人。他的判决是不诚实的。所以现在文化战争正在全面爆发。因此它确实是一场文化。你可以将其描述为文化战争。
The polarization is starting to happen, as always happens when each side starts to kind of impose stereotypes on the other. But that's not all that's happening. That's not the only reason. Because there's a lot of high politics in this. There is also a lot of high politics going on as well. So this region is not integrated into one of the kind of unitary kingdoms that are starting to emerge in this period. So nominally, you know, you have the kings of France, the kings of England, both kind of claim an overlordship over it. And the king of England is Henry II in the mid 12th century.
两极分化开始出现，正如当每一方开始对另一方强加刻板印象时总是会发生的那样。但这并不是全部正在发生的事情。这并不是唯一的理由。因为这里面有很多高层政治。其中也有很多高层政治在发挥作用。所以这个地区并没有融入这一时期开始出现的某种单一王国之中。因此名义上，你知道的，你有法国国王、英国国王，两者都声称对其拥有最高统治权。而英国国王则是12世纪中叶的亨利二世。
He marries Eleanor of Aquitaine. And he says that Eleanor of Aquitaine has brought with her as part of her dowry these lands and that therefore they should be subject to him right and so in 1159 Henry launches an attempt to conquer Toulouse that is a disaster and Henry is furious about this and basically he launches a kind of vendetta against everybody in the region and the counts of Toulouse in particular, all of whom are called Remor. And so, More makes the point that one consequence of his vendetta is that almost everything we read of the development of heresy in the region of Toulouse over the next 20 years comes from English sources. Because accusing your enemies of heresy is an absolutely, you know, it's an absolute, by this point, it's becoming a default way to target your opponents.
他娶了阿基坦的埃莉诺。并且他说阿基坦的埃莉诺作为她嫁妆的一部分带来了这些土地，因此这些土地应该臣服于他，对吧。所以在1159年，亨利发动了征服图卢兹的尝试，那是一场灾难，亨利对此勃然大怒，基本上他对该地区的所有人以及特别是图卢兹伯爵（他们都叫雷蒙德）发动了一场宿怨。因此，莫（More）指出，他的宿怨产生的一个后果是，在接下来20年里，我们读到的关于图卢兹地区异端发展的几乎所有内容都来自英国资料。因为指控你的敌人是异端绝对是，你知道的，绝对是，到了这个地步，它正成为针对你的对手的默认方式。
And so, it's Henry II, he plays a big part in establishing the the image of this region is kind of riddled with heretics does he absolutely and in 1163 there's a council at tor with the pope the pope is there yeah and henry ii is there and all these kind of promulgations are made and and the canons gets heresy it's it's kind of clearly been sharpened by Henry II that they're being targeted at the Count of Toulouse. Right. So in other words, he's basically saying it's a region of deplorables left behind. So you haven't signed up to your revolution. And you know what? You should give me sanction to go in, clean this up. I'll sort it out. Yeah, pretty much. I mean, yes, the modern analogy might be people saying that, you know, your enemies are communists or fascists or far left or far right or whatever. Yeah.
所以，正是亨利二世，他在塑造该地区充满异端的形象方面发挥了重要作用，不是吗？绝对是的。在1163年，在图尔召开了一次由教皇出席的会议，教皇在那里，是的，亨利二世也在那里，所有这些公告都颁布了，教规涉及异端，这显然被亨利二世强化了，他们的目标是图卢兹伯爵。对。换句话说，他基本上是在说这是一个被遗忘的、充满可悲之人的地区。所以你们没有签署你们的革命。你知道吗？你应该授权我进去，清理这个。我会解决的。是的，差不多。我的意思是，是的，现代的比喻可能是人们说，你知道的，你的敌人是共产主义者、法西斯主义者、极左或极右等等。是的。
You just tar them with the extremists. I mean, it's what people do on social media all the time, isn't it? Yes, exactly. You don't slightly disagree with me. You're a bigot. Exactly. Yes, exactly so. But adding to the complication is that the Count of Toulouse, who I said is always called Raymond, he is in a constant state
你只是给他们贴上极端分子的标签。我的意思是，这就是人们在社交媒体上一直在做的事，不是吗？是的，绝对是的。你并非稍微不同意我的看法。你是个顽固的偏执狂。绝对是的。确实如此。但使情况更加复杂的是，图卢兹伯爵（我刚才说过他总是叫雷蒙德）一直处于一种状态
of rivalry with the Viscount of Béziers and Carcassonne, who are two kind of large towns, large cities in the south of France. And they're a family called the Troncheval. And they also are endlessly kind of chucking accusations of heresy at each other. Yeah. So you put in your notes, they're always accusing each other of being fascists or racists or something.'s that kind of thing yeah yeah um and in 1165 raymond counter to lose summons all all the magnets all the bishops all the kind of big wigs to a big summit which is specifically designed to identify heresy in the region and basically kind of dump it all over all over the vicomte of bezier and carcassonne and both kind of dump it all over the Viscont of Béziers and Carcassonne.
与贝济耶和卡卡松的子爵（这是法国南部的两个大镇、大城市）处于竞争之中。他们是一个叫特龙谢瓦尔（Troncheval）的家族。他们也无休止地互相指责对方是异端。是的。所以在你的笔记里，他们总是互相指责对方是法西斯主义者或种族主义者之类的话。就是那种事，对，对，嗯，在1165年，图卢兹伯爵雷蒙德召集了所有的显贵、所有的主教、所有的大人物召开了一次大型峰会，其专门目的就是为了识别该地区的异端，并基本上把这一切都归咎于贝济耶和卡卡松的子爵，双方都把这一切归咎于贝济耶和卡卡松的子爵。
And both sides are doing it, but it's an incredibly dangerous game because, of course, in the broader world, you're getting, you know, in Rome and in the universities, this increasing paranoia about heresy. And so when you have Innocent III coming to the papal throne, you know, this is a disaster waiting to happen and so he is looking at this region and he's getting you know he's getting messages left right and center telling him that this is absolutely pestilential that there are it's complete breeding ground for heresy and something should be done and so innocent he turns to the king of france philippe augustus philip ii yeah you know the great french French king who kind of moulds and shapes France as the greatest monarchy in Christendom.
而且双方都在这么做，但这是一个极其危险的游戏，因为当然，在更广阔的世界里，你知道的，在罗马和各大大学里，对异端的偏执日益加剧。因此，当英诺森三世登上教皇宝座时，你知道，这将是一场不可避免的灾难，所以他看着这个地区，不断收到来自各方的消息，告诉他这里简直是个瘟疫区，完全是异端的滋生地，必须采取行动。于是，英诺森转向了法国国王腓力·奥古斯都，也就是腓力二世，是的，你知道的，那个伟大的法国国王，他将法国塑造并打造成为了基督教世界中最强大的君主。
No friend of Richard the Lionheart. Or indeed John. And he says, look, go down there and sort it out. But Philip doesn't want to do that because he's got bigger fish to fry. He's trying to, you know, he's trying to see off John. He's got Otto IV. He says, you know, I'm menaced by two lions in the form of the king of england and and the emperor and basically i need to see them off right paris is the center of you know northern france is the center of his interests he doesn't
他可不是狮心王理查的朋友。约翰王也不是。他说，听着，去南方把这事解决掉。但腓力不想这么做，因为他有更重要的事情要处理。他正试图，你知道的，他正试图摆脱约翰。他还有奥托四世。他说，你知道的，我受到英格兰国王和皇帝这两头雄狮的威胁，基本上我需要摆脱他们。巴黎才是中心，你知道的，法国北部才是他利益的中心，他不想
want to get diverted by getting sucked into the kind of the bog of the south so he refuses so innocent keeps saying go on go and have a crack at the heretics in the south of France. And Philippe keeps saying, no, I'm not going to do it. At the same time, Innocent is trying to get Raymond, I think he's the sixth of the Count of Toulouse, basically to kind of get him to heal. And so he's threatening with excommunication and telling him that he will be excommunicated unless he expels all the heretics. And Raymond, who's been busy accusing all his enemies of heresy actually he doesn't want to do it because he doesn't you know he's kind of basically made it up i mean not completely but he doesn't you know he so innocent is saying you know he's he says wounds that do not respond to the treatment of a poultice should be cut away with a knife
被南方的泥潭卷入而分心，所以他拒绝了。因此，英诺森不断地说，去吧，去打击法国南部的异端。而腓力一直说，不，我不会这么做。与此同时，英诺森正试图让雷蒙德——我想他是图卢兹伯爵六世——基本上让他有所收敛。因此，他威胁要对其实行绝罚，并告诉他，除非驱逐所有异端，否则他将被绝罚。而雷蒙德一直忙于指控他所有的政敌为异端，实际上他不想这么做，因为他不想，你知道的，这基本上是他捏造出来的——也不是完全捏造，但他就是不想，你知道的。所以英诺森说，你知道的，他说“不听膏药治疗的伤口，必须用刀切除”
but this is the kind of language that raymond very, very opposed to. He doesn't want to start cutting out people, you know, who may be his servants, his friends, his liege men. Well, not least because they're not. So to be absolutely clear, they're not doing secret rituals. They're not believing in anything wacky. They're actually just believing what everybody believed a few decades by and large by and large by and large i mean they do have their own kind of heretical takes on things but everyone does yes because there's never been uniform because there's never been a uniform a kind of institutional right and ideological uniformity imposed before that is what is going on yeah and and so of course
但雷蒙德非常非常反对这种言论。他不想开始切除那些可能他的仆人、他的朋友、他的封臣的人。嗯，不仅是因为他们根本不是。所以必须绝对澄清的是，他们没有进行秘密仪式。他们不相信什么古怪的东西。实际上他们只是相信几十年来大家一直相信的东西，大致上，大致上，大致上，我的意思是他们对事物确实有自己的一套异端看法，但每个人都有，是的，因为从来没有过统一，因为从来没有过统一的、某种机构层面的正确性和意识形态统一在此之前被强加过，这就是正在发生的事情，是的，而且当然
but but but raymond is very very you know he doesn't want to i mean it would create havoc it would be terrible. It would devastate his land. So he refuses. But he feels the breath of the Pope down his neck. And so in 1205, he says, yes, okay, I will expel all the heretics from his land. And he says this, and then he does absolutely nothing. And so two years later, he is visited by two papal emissaries.
但是，但是雷蒙德非常非常，你知道的，他不想——我的意思是这会造成混乱，这太可怕了。这会毁灭他的土地。所以他拒绝了。但他感到了教皇逼近的威胁。因此在1205年，他说，好的，好的，我会将所有异端从他的土地上驱逐出去。他这么说了，然后却什么也没做。因此两年后，两名教皇使者拜访了他。
And one of them is a man called Peter de Castelnau, who is the Pope's official envoy to the region. And another is a guy called Arnold Amelric, who is the abbot of the Cistercian Abbey of Citeaux. And the Cistercians have been very, very prominent in visiting the region and arguing with the good men and reporting back in alarm terms to the Pope about the prevalence of heresy in the region and arguing with the good men and reporting back in alarm terms to the Pope about the prevalence of heresy in the region. And they basically lay it on the line. And they tell Raymond that he has to join an armed league, his own liegemen, his own vassals, that he has to expel Jewish officials, again, on whom he's very dependent that basically he has to cut away everything that has sustained
其中一人名叫皮埃尔·德·卡斯特尔诺，他是教皇驻该地区的官方特使。另一人名叫阿尔诺·阿梅里克，是西笃会西托修道院的院长。西笃会员一直非常积极地访问该地区，与那些好人争论，并以危言耸听的语气向教皇汇报该地区异端的盛行情况，与那些好人争论，并以危言耸听的语气向教皇汇报该地区异端的盛行情况。他们基本上把话挑明了。他们告诉雷蒙德，他必须加入一个武装同盟，与他自己的封臣、他自己的附庸对抗，他必须驱逐犹太官员——同样，他非常依赖这些犹太官员——基本上他必须切除所有支撑着
his own administration you know and this is a kind of terrible thing raymond can't really do that because it would destroy his his ability to to rule as count and so he refuses and he's excommunicated and you know this is this is very very alarming for him because he's now very nervous that the king phil, will come for him. Actually, Philip doesn't, but Raymond doesn't know this. And so early in 1208, he writes to Peter de Castelnau and he says, look, I'm ready to surrender. I'll do what you say, because he's so nervous about what's going to happen otherwise. So early January 1208, Raymond and Peter de Castelnau meet at a place called Saint-Gilles-du-Gas, which is right on, almost on the coast, south of France.
他自己的行政管理的东西，你知道的，这是一件极其糟糕的事，雷蒙德实际上做不到这一点，因为这会摧毁他作为伯爵的统治能力，所以他拒绝了，并因此被绝罚。你知道的，这对他来说非常非常惊恐，因为他现在非常紧张，担心法国国王腓力会来找他。实际上腓力没有来，但雷蒙德并不知道这一点。因此在1208年初，他写信给皮埃尔·德·卡斯特尔诺，说，听着，我准备投降了。我会按你说的做，因为他对接下来可能发生的事情感到无比紧张。因此在1208年1月上旬，雷蒙德和皮埃尔·德·卡斯特尔诺在一个叫圣吉尔-迪加斯的地方会面，那里几乎就在法国南部的海岸线上。
Gilles was a hermit, has a kind of famous church, famous pilgrimage center. And Raymond tries to arrive at some kind of compromise. De Castelnau is absolutely obdurate, refuses to. The meeting breaks up. No consensus has been arrived at. The next morning, de Castelnau is crossing the river Rhone when he is ambushed by a knight who is never identified. Oh my word.
吉尔曾是一位隐士，拥有一座著名的教堂和著名的朝圣中心。雷蒙德试图达成某种妥协。德·卡斯特尔诺极其顽固，拒绝妥协。会谈破裂了。没有达成任何共识。第二天早上，德·卡斯特尔诺在渡过罗讷河时，遭到了一名身份不明的骑士的伏击。我的天啊。
And gets run through, you know, gets stabbed in the back. And de Castelnau dies. And it's clear that it wasn't Raymond who commissioned it because he had everything to lose from it. But when the news is brought to the Pope, a poet in due course will write the immortal line,
然后被长剑贯穿，你知道的，被从背后刺死。德·卡斯特尔诺就这样死了。很明显，这不是雷蒙德指使的，因为这件事对他的损害最大。但当消息传到教皇那里时，一位诗人在日后写下了不朽的诗句：
when the Pope heard of his legate's death, you can be sure he was not pleased. And this poet was, he's a man who's writing in Occitan. So the language, the longer doc, the language of the region. A man called William of Tudela william of tudela and this poem in occitan is called the caso de la cruzada song of the crusade and it's the first use of that word crusade so this idea that the holy wars can be fought against enemies of god that reach all the way back to 1095 when the Pope Urban II had summoned warriors to go and relieve Jerusalem from the Saracens.
当教皇听到他的特使死讯时，你可以确信他绝不高兴。这位诗人，是一个用奥克语写作的人。也就是这种语言，奥克语，该地区的语言。一个名叫纪尧姆·德·图德拉的人，纪尧姆·德·图德拉。这首用奥克语写成的长诗被称为《阿尔比十字军之歌》（Canso de la crosada），这是“十字军”这个词的第一次使用。因此，这种观念认为，圣战可以针对上帝的敌人进行，这一理念可以一直追溯到1095年，当时教皇乌尔班二世召唤勇士们去从萨拉森人手中解救耶路撒冷。
Various holy wars since then had been launched, but never before had the word crusade been used or a variant on crusade to describe this war. And it demonstrates the full horror of what is about to be visited on the region ruled by Raymond. A crusade against a region where the enemies that they're looking for don't even exist effectively.
自那以后，各种圣战陆续发起，但此前从未用过“十字军”这个词或其变体来描述这场战争。这展现了即将降临到雷蒙德统治地区的恐怖之全貌。一场针对这样一个地区的十字军东征，在那里他们寻找的敌人实际上根本不存在。
Where the secret shadowy church, you know, I read a book when I was a teenager in which people always dressing up in white robes and purifying themselves and, you know, behaving in that sort of stereotypical conspiracy theory way with occult symbols and stuff. And absolutely, you know, that was just, that was not happening. Well, I mean, to reiterate, there are, by the standards of the Roman church, there are heretics there. I mean, they clearly hold people there are people who hold heretical beliefs but it's not the kind of black and white the manichean vision yes that the pope has and this is another of the paradoxes that i said that in some ways
那个秘密阴暗的教会，你知道的，我十几岁时读过一本书，里面的人总是穿着白袍，净化自己，你知道的，以那种带有神秘符号之类的典型阴谋论方式行事。绝对的，你知道的，那根本没有发生。好吧，我的意思是，重申一下，按照罗马教会的标准，那里确实有异端。我的意思是，那里显然有持异端信仰的人，但这并不是教皇所拥有的那种非黑即白、摩尼教式的愿景。是的，这也是我之前说过的另一个悖论
it's the roman church that because it wants to purify everything you know that that that it's it's it's the servants of the roman church who are the Catharoi, the Puritans, the Cathars. They're the ones whose mission it is to cleanse the world. And in the same way, this idea that there is a dualist church, a church that sees the world as divided into rival powers of good and evil. Actually, this isn't believed by the heretics, but it's kind of believed by Innocent III. He believes that believed by innocent the third right you know he believes that the power of the devil is manifest and that it is threatening with christendom with ruin and the results are well i mean apocalyptic perhaps is the right word to use so if you've
正是罗马教会，因为它想要净化一切，你知道的，罗马教会的仆人正是那些卡塔利派（Catharoi）、清教徒、卡塔利派。正是他们的使命去净化世界。同样，这种认为存在一个二元论教会的观念，一个将世界视为分裂为善恶对立力量的教会。实际上，异端并不这样认为，但英诺森三世某种程度上是这样认为的。他认为——英诺森三世确实这样认为，你知道的——他认为恶魔的力量显而易见，并且正在威胁着基督教世界的毁灭，其结果是——好吧，我的意思是，用“末日般的”来形容或许最贴切。所以如果你
been there tom you just said you want to see a cathar mate look in the mirror i would you want to see a manichean look in the mirror and the m. You want to see a Manichean? Look in the mirror. And the Merovingian bloodline? Not there. Not there. Oh, how disappointing. So we will return on Thursday with the heart-stopping climax of this story. Or, of course, if you just can't wait to hear about the Albigensian Crusade, Europe's first genocide. And I hear people saying that to me all the time, that they're looking forward to hearing about this. Tom, what they have to do, they go to www.restishistorypod.com. If you're a regular listener, you will know that off by heart, of course. And you can sign up to our members club and you can get early access to this truly gory and blood-soaked tale. It's a horrible, horrible story.
去过那里，汤姆，你刚才说你想见一个卡塔利派的朋友，照照镜子就行了。你想见一个摩尼教徒吗？照照镜子。墨洛温王朝的血脉？没有。没有。哦，太令人失望了。所以我们将在周四带着这个故事惊心动魄的高潮回归。或者，当然，如果你等不及想听到关于阿尔比十字军东征——欧洲的第一次种族灭绝的故事。我听到人们一直在对我说，他们非常期待听到这个故事。汤姆，他们需要做的就是访问 www.restishistorypod.com。如果你是老听众，你当然对这个网址烂熟于心。你可以注册我们的会员俱乐部，并提前收听这个真正血腥、充满杀戮的故事。这是一个可怕、可怕的故事。
Yeah. Brace yourself for some horror. But I think the listeners actually quite like horrible stories. Well, we'll find out when we check the listening figures. All right. We will see you next time for a horrible story. Goodbye. Okay. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
是的，做好面对恐怖的准备吧。但我认为听众其实挺喜欢恐怖故事的。好吧，等我们查看收听数据时就知道了。好的，我们下次再见，带来一个可怕的故事。再见。好的。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八卦精选。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获取独家单集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。